it used to be you know college is a
place for open dialogue and open debate
but we find free speech zones we found
unconstitutional speech policies and
that's our goal with this campaign our
national fight for free speech campaign
is how do we tap with them and how do we
how we change them in reform i am
Nicoletta threes and TV today we're
talking with clip Maloney jr. he's the
executive director for young americans
for liberty cliff thanks for talking to
us Nick pleasure with you young
americans for liberty y al for short is
an outgrowth of Ron Paul's presidential
campaigns you try to get younger
americans for liberty to become
libertarian and start thinking about
that stuff
what are the big things that you're
working on these days sure so as you
know we started back in $MONTH 2008 2009
out of ron paul's campaign started about
a hundred chapters and today I'm happy
to say we're over 750 chapters on
college campuses nationwide the two
major things were focusing on first
being our fall recruitment drive our
broad stroke effort to reach as many
college kids we possibly can with these
ideas of principles so what what does
that mean what kind of activities to do
on campus and where are the hot spots
where students are like holy cow this
where you been all my life
sounds great so we try to make politics
sexy the best way to say it right we try
to reach kids are you can't I just threw
up a little bit we try to reach kids
with these ideas we do that through
activism right so real events with
college campuses are supposed to be all
about taking ideas to students and
having these discussions and so we
package this we've got 16 different
activism events that we offer to our
students chapters for example something
like visualize the debt where they'll
build out you know right now about 20
trillion right so maybe we have 19
trillion those numbers across the campus
quad and they're starting discussions
with students and you know what is what
is 190 what all these zeros and they
started questions about what is the dead
we talk about it
other things we've done as an event
called incarceration nation where we're
really calling out you know this this
idea that we should have mandatory
minimums and just saying we need
criminal justice reform right so we try
to find different ideas for different
events to bring people in introduce them
to our idea
is and expand our reach on college
campuses what are the what are the
issues that students respond to what
what's that what's at the top of their
my god this is an outrage right so
usually current events anytime we can
tie them in we connect much better
so another major push we have right now
is something called yowls fight for free
speech campaign and that is an effort
due to all these recent you know
outrages over what is allowed to be set
on campus this PC culture and what we're
doing is we are literally going after
what these campuses called free speech
zones so for those that haven't heard of
this you know free speech zone is an
area let's say 20 feet by 20 feet zone
that a school says you know what they're
allowed to speak freely in that zone
this America right we have the First
Amendment and so what we're doing is
we're targeting these free speech on
campuses your public universities right
so they're they're bound by
constitutional of you know rules about
First Amendment speech correct
taxpayer-funded public universities and
what we do is we do a specific activism
event that the other free speech
let me give an example so we'll do a
Yale free speech ball then what this is
a huge beach ball that will blow up
let's say six feet you know by six feet
ball and the student leaders will blow
them up and then roll them around and
they're all just asked you know students
a [ __ ] exercise your right to free speech
use this sharpie and share your
expression and we've had incidents where
campuses you know we'll we'll have
college bureaucrats or security guards
on campus come out and tell the students
we need a permit you know or you you
know you're not allowed to do that and I
take it you're you're filming that
you're tweeting it your facebook again
right the other component of this is to
share it as much as we can through media
to really call out you know this facade
that is free speech on this campus what
are you know what are some of the worst
campuses that you guys encountered for
free speech we had an incident
university of delaware last semester
where we had a student handing out papi
constitutions he was stopped you know
from the from campus security with
dangerous document Hawkman I guess you
know just handing out papi constitutions
he was stopped saying need a permit to
do so right
from Mount university just last week in
west virginia had an incident where
students were out talking about free
speech getting students the signup get
him interested young americans for
liberty and the school administrators
said that they were being too outgoing
with their recruitment right they need a
permit or they need some sort of
permission to be out talking to people
and so I think that all these cases are
just flipping on its head
it used to be you know college is a
place for open dialogue and open debate
but we find free speech zones we found
unconstitutional speech policies and
that's our goal with this campaign our
national by free speech campaign is how
do we tap with them and how do we how do
we change them and reform who are the
students are attracting is their kind of
common set of characteristics about them
is one part of the country you know kind
of more interested than the other what
can you give a kind of sense of that let
me bring up the current election right
for all that it's worth it's you know it
came back and just got back to a young
americans for liberty and I wouldn't
know what to expect you know there's all
this going on and what we're finding is
that students are are that much more
engaged because you have individuals
this isn't a carry and a bush or a
corner Busch race right this is a trump
you know when you look at the two major
candidates everybody knows who they are
but there's no way you mean Gary Johnson
and jill stein correct correct of course
but yet between Trump and Hillary these
are oversized mannequin right but nobody
you know nobody on these campuses are
excited right and what we're finding is
that's an opening for young americans
for liberty is an opening for us to
present real solutions real policy
because what we get right now is all
celebrity it's all personality nobody's
talking about issues and so when you see
a student on campus is doing activism is
doing fun projects to present our ideas
of Liberty it's engaging like this is
actually something that that matters a
solution is this a particularly
responsive moment that your funding on
campuses are among young people for
libertarianism i think that the ideas
that we're presenting we've never seen
such an interest from folks and I think
that's where it's our responsibility to
step in and fill this vacuum and so I
think the more that we do that the more
that we take this opportunity this is a
time to double down
right you've got to have somebody step
in and the other thing is it's time to
lead and not react right we believe with
that positive narrative of Liberty if
you present these principles you know
that we all hold the year right sober
foreign policy real privacy right i mean
things that you know what this new Stone
movie should make very clear case for
everybody out there limited government a
broad sense how debt is killing people
we have college students who are making
minimum wage they're working 20-hour
weeks right and they're they're losing
thirty percent with him into the
government talk a bit about you know it
seems to me that Hillary or certainly
Bernie Sanders like ron paul had a
pretty good following pretty strong
following among young people and on
college campuses
what's interesting is that Bernie
Sanders got there by saying i'm going to
give you free health care i'm going to
give you free college I'm gonna give you
you know free parking I whatever ron
paul got there through a very different
set of policy concerns is the
libertarian message of saying let's make
government smaller and more efficient
and the places it needs to be but let's
make let's shrink it is that enough to
blue younger people who oftentimes seem
to be like oh you know $25,000 tonight
i'm thirty thousand dollars in debt and
this this old guy from Vermont not from
Texas is saying help you will cover my
bills can libertarianism compete with
that
yeah I mean I think we have to start
responsibility to do that and one of the
things I love is freedom not free stuff
but i think that you know as you look at
why were people attracted the Bernie
sure I mean I think you know the broad
strokes of you know is honest right I
need somebody who's anti-establishment
and he's you know gonna going to be
honest with people and just truthful I
think that was what was more appealing
and then you got to some of these
socialist policies and you realize well
hey guys you know economics teaches us
that this can happen and once again it's
another reason that liberty-minded
limited government individuals and we
have to step 4 we have to educate people
and this is the battle we face on campus
is you know are people going to be in
the young americans for liberty crowd
are you gonna be somebody who who thinks
that individual liberty not government
can create solutions or you're going to
continue to turn to the government and I
think the more that people do that the
more that we see people coming on
way that's great to hear and talk a
little bit about you got activated and
politics by ron paul his presidential
campaign 2008 talk a little bit about
what was his appeal to you and how did
it
how did it make you kind of think
different than the world in which were
raised sure i come from a family of
blue-collar Democrat and christian
conservative mother you know but i think
that i found ran ron paul and it really
opened my eyes to a different way right
a way that made sense and obviously
later on realizing it was this
liberty-minded libertarian path that
said social tolerance but at the same
time you know limiting government
finding ways that we can get economics
in order and what I what I realized was
especially the foreign policy and of it
right
he was actually talking about you know
why why do people dislike the united
states right understanding what a sober
foreign policy looks like and you see
people right now people like Rand Paul
you know who still leading the crusade
to say you know maybe we shouldn't be
giving out billions and billions dollars
of dollars and in foreign aid
individuals we need a same voice and I
think that the Republican Party and
honestly just liberty-minded people in
any way any way that we can push these
ideas forward I think that it's about
finding every vehicle that we can find
and I'd love to have you no more college
students come over young americans for
liberty and start to share that message
with all right well we will leave it
there
we have been talking with Cliff Bologna
jr. he's the executive director of young
americans for liberty
thanks so much cliff thanks name for
reason TV i'm nicholas lee